well some changes in mortgage lending
could mean it's easier for you to move
into the home of your dreams here to
talk about that and more is Kirby
Scofield owner of Scofield Realty the
sponsor of this segment Kirby good to
have you with us as always one of the
changes we're talking about is regarding
private mortgage insurance so for the
for those who are kind of new to this
those old ones it was on that new rate
table oh go ahead you tell me thank you
okay so what everything that hit in the
news last week was the rates yeah and
that for lower credit it was going to be
a discount and higher credit you're
going to get charged more and kayak
caused an uproar
um the reality to it is there's three
things to it is
um they did change they are charging it
um
if your air if the area income you're
under a hundred percent then you can
qualify for the better rate in other
words if if the median income if you're
below that yeah the area meeting income
which says 60 Grand okay you're below
you qualify but the other big thing is a
lot of people are FHA mortgage
um
512 is roughly like it's 494 and then
you put the three and a half down it's
like 512 right now is our loan value
512k FHA Loans uh VA loans they are not
affected by that rate news that
everybody was talking about okay uh the
other thing that we learned today from
Robert Coomer group our lender
um who's local here in Henderson is the
pocket's kind of like 700 740 credit
score they are second kind of higher but
um if you do not do the full 20 down and
you actually that kind of does PMI if
you have the private mortgage insurance
in there that changes the rate but if
you're the 760 and above credit score
which a lot of people with the great
credit scores were like what the heck am
I getting charged for right yeah you're
getting NCAA change okay so they did it
in different tiers it's just when it
first hit the news last week it went
yeah a lot of people went crazy and said
oh if you have bad credit you actually
have an advantage that's not true
correct it kind of levels playing field
but there is a little pocket there
that's set I I don't know if it's a 680
or 700 forget I know it's up to 740.
yeah in that pocket range you'll want to
look at the options as far as putting
less down possibly will actually maybe
be worth more and then paying off that
PMI later really briefly I do want to
cover this because it's a seller's
market you're always looking for people
to represent sellers and buyers and you
have incentive for people to jump on
board with you yeah I think you can do
so 2500 we're offering as an agent
sign-on bonus we are looking to scale
our team we have plenty of buyers plenty
of Sellers and I need agents that's
great yeah good problem to have right
curvy it's always good to have you thank
you thank you for being here we want to
thank Scofield Realty for sponsoring
this segment they are looking for new
Talent 2500 signing bonus terms apply
and uh just go to
scofieldrealty.com to learn more or call
that phone number on the screen we'll be
right back